يفلت مره اخرى عقال العمله الوطنيه في
ايران يسجل الريال مستوى غير مسبوق
متجاوزا
36000 للدولار الواحد كان ذلك اخر مشهد في
انحدار استمر منذ فرض العقوبات الامريكيه
على الاقل
خسرت فيه العمله الايرانيه كثيره من
قيمتها
تكثر اسباب هذا الهبوط التاريخيه الجديد
في البلاد تعيش ازمه احتجاجات دخلت شهرها
الثاني تقول وزاره الاقتصاد ان ذلك دفع
مواطنين لتحويل جزء من مدخراتهم الى
الدولار وطن داخلي تزامن مع اخر خارجي
تمثل في توقف المفاوضات النوويه
وتضاؤل الامال برفع العقوبات
وزادت الطين بالله عقوبه اوروبيه وامريكيه
على خلفيه الاحتجاجات واتهام ايران بتزويد
روسيا بالمسيرات
لاستخدامها في حربها على اوكرانيا لكن ثم
تمي يقولوا في البرلمان ان العزه في
الموازنه البالغ نحو سبعه مليارات دولار
دفع الحكومه الى رفع سعر الدولار
في الموازنه واللجوء الى التلاعب باسعار
العملات في السوق ليس الحله الانجاح
والافضل تقديم خطه اقتصاديه لانقاذ الوضع
المركزي للسيطره على السوق العملاء
فاتح شراء الدولار عبر قنوات الرسميه
الكترونيه
واعلنت السلطات واعتقال عشرات مما وصفتهم
بممثلين الاضطرابات في السوق واغلاق مئات
الحسابات المصرفيه بالعمله الاجنبيه
تمثل علاجا مؤقتا وهبوط العمله الوطنيه
سيتواصل مع غياب تنميه الاقتصاديه
واستمرار
مع كل هبوط للعمله المحليه في ايران يرتفع
معدل التضخم ويزداد معه الضغط الاقتصادي
على المواطن اثار تتضاعف مع وصول التضخم
والبطاله الى ارقام قياسيه
اجتماعيه وامنيه وسياسيه واقتصاديه تسجل
العمله في ايران هبوطا جديدا لتزيد الضغوط
على المواطن وتضع الحكومه امام تحديات
جديده عمر هواش الجزيره طه